gunshots ring out in downtown Louisville
prompting police to warn passers-by to
take cover
police arrived within three minutes of
an 8 30 a.m call that a gunman was
firing inside Old National Bank smashing
through the glass of the locked bank
they engaged the gunman killing him
officers arrived on scene and
encountered the suspect almost
immediately still firing gun gunshots
officers exchanged gunshots with that
suspect and ultimately that suspect did
die at the scene
but by that time four people were killed
at a bank where Kentucky's Governor
keeps an account a fifth victim died
later we lost four children of God today
one of whom was one of my closest
friends
Tommy Elliott helped me build my law
career
help me become governor
gave me advice on being a good dad
it's one of the people I talk to most in
the world and very rarely
were we talking about my job
he was an incredible friend
nine victims have been taken to the
hospital including three police officers
one shot in the head the gunman has been
identified as Connor sturgeon a 23 year
old Bank employee police say he streamed
the entire attack on social media
hours later a SWAT team searched his
home
let's be clear about what this was
this was an evil Act of targeted
violence on day 100 of 2023 it was the
146th mass shooting of the Year
according to the gun violence archive a
little over two hours later another
gunman killed a man at a Louisville
Community College and fled police say it
was unrelated John hendren Al Jazeera